the justice department is launching an
investigation of the phoenix police
department
over allegations of using excessive
force now this is a biden
administration's third investigation of
a law enforcement agency
following probes of the minneapolis and
louisville police
police departments attorney general
merrick garland says the review in
phoenix
will examine any pattern of unlawful
policing including
deadly force discriminatory behavior and
retaliation
jeff begues looks at the history that
led to this new investigation
in recent years phoenix police have
gotten a reputation for too
often using excessive force
one case in particular stands out in
2019
officers pointed guns at a black family
threatening to shoot the father in front
of his fiance and children
after one of the toddlers took a doll
from a dollar store
that case and others in the arizona city
will now be part of the justice
department's pattern or practice
investigation
federal civil rights investigators will
assess all types of use of force by
phoenix police
including deadly force the investigation
will determine whether the phoenix
police department engages in a pattern
or practice of violations of the
constitution
or federal law the training itself the
content
was the absolute worst training i've
ever had in 2019
cbs this morning investigated police
practices in the city
according to a report by the arizona
republic the year before
phoenix police had 44 officer involved
shootings
the most in the country and most of
those incidents involve black
or native americans there are some
people who
think well are phoenix police trigger
happy
there are some people who think a lot of
things my agency is unafraid of the
truth
if there's something we can learn let's
learn it let's fix it the department
enacted changes in tactics
including ending neck restraints and
tracking when officers draw their
weapons why does the place of ice exist
even mandated implicit bias training
which didn't
seem to leave an impression on some
officers who spoke freely after we
agreed to conceal their identity
will it change how you do your job no
why not
i don't think i was doing it incorrectly
to begin with on thursday
chief williams acknowledged that there
was room for improvement so i'm looking
forward to them
seeing what we've done right and also
what we can improve on
the doj investigation will likely take
more than
a year to complete you can expect more
of these types of
pattern or practice investigations from
this attorney general the previous
administration all but
abandoned federal oversight of local
police departments
glad all right jeff looking forward to
the results of that investigation thank
you very much